so we have the graph of y equals f of x
right over here and what we want to do
is figure out the limit of f of x as x
approaches negative 4.
so what does that mean
well a limit is
saying what is my function approach as
the input of that function approaches in
this case negative 4 as the input
approaches a value and as we see in this
example the function doesn't necessarily
have to be even defined at that value we
can see f of negative 4 you go to x
equals negative 4
and you see that f of negative 4 is
undefined so this is not defined
but as we'll see even though the
function isn't defined there the limit
might be defined there and actually it
could go the other way around sometimes
a function is defined there but the
limit is not and we'll see that in
future videos but let's just get an
understanding here what's going on as x
approaches negative 4 as x approaches
negative 4 from values greater than
negative 4 and from values less than
negative 4. well let's first think about
values greater than negative 4. so when
x is negative 1 this is f of negative
one this is f of negative two this is f
of negative three this is f of negative
three point five
this is f of negative three point nine
nine this is f of negative three point
nine nine nine nine nine nine and so you
can see the value of our function as x
gets closer and closer to negative four
from values greater than negative four
seems to be approaching six
and let's see if that's true from the
other direction some from values less
than negative 4. so this is f of
negative 7 f of negative 6. this is f of
negative
5. it looks like it's around 7. this is
f of negative 4.5 f of negative 4.1
f of negative 4.01
f of negative
4.0001 it looks like it's getting
awfully it's going to be a little bit
more than six so it seems as we get
closer and closer to six as we get
closer and closer to
x equals negative four the value of our
function is approaching
positive six